♪
>> Tucker: COLLEGE STUDENTS
TEND TO GET STRESSED OUT BY
FINALS IF YOU ATTEND THE
UNIVERSITY OF UTAH, YOU HAVE
AN OPTION.
IT'S CALLED THE CRY CLOSET.
THE CLOSET IS THE CREATION
OF A ART STUDENT EXISTS FOR
INTO IT FOR 10 MINUTES OF
CRYING TO HELP COPE WITH THE
TEST.
THE CLOSET INTERIOR INCLUDES
FUZZY STUFFED ANIMALS FOR
MAXIMUM COPING.
THE QUESTION IS IT TIME TO
GO NATIONAL WITH THIS.
WEEPING WARDROBES ERECTED
ACROSS THIS FRAGILE COUNTRY.
ONLY ONE WOMAN MAKE THE CASE
FOR THAT CATHY AREU
PUBLISHING OF CATALINA
MAGAZINE AND SHERPA.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> Tucker: COLLEGE, OF
COURSE, IS THE LEAST
STRESSFUL PLACE THERE IS.
>> LEAST STRESSFUL?
>> Tucker: SURE.
DID YOU GO TO CLASS FOR TWO
HOURS A WEEK AND GET DRUNK
THE REST OF THE TIME.
>> OH, COME ON.
THAT'S NOT EVERYONE'S
EXPERIENCE.
IT'S VERY STRESSFUL.
THEY ARE LEARNING.
THE FUTURE.
THESE ARE OUR CITIZENS OF
TOMORROW.
AND THEY ARE LEARNING AS
MUCH AS THEY CAN.
THEY ARE AS STRESSED AS CAN
BE THEY NEED PSYCHOLOGICAL
HELP.
THEY NEED THIS BIOENERGETIC
WAY TO GET OUT THEIR STRESS.
10 MINUTES OF A GOOD CRY IN
A CRY CLOSET TO THEN BE
PREPARED TO TAKE THOSE EXAMS
FROM EVERYTHING THEY HAVE
LEARNED IN THOSE CLASSES.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T HAVE
TIME FOR TOUR DEFINE
BIOENERGETIC ON THE SHOW SO
WE WILL LET THAT PASS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: DOES THIS SUGGEST
SOMETHING ABOUT THE
FRAGILITY OF THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH.
IF YOU ARE SO STRESSED ABOUT
TAKING SOME DUMB TEST AT
SOME DUMB SCHOOL DOESN'T
THAT MEAN YOU ARE ON THE
EDGE OF A BREAKDOWN?
>> NO.
DON'T WE ALL NEED A GOOD OLD
FASHIONED CRY?
THIS IS AN OLD FASHIONED
REMEDY TO A MODERN DAY
PROBLEM.
IT'S JUST ABOUT CRYING 10
MINUTES OF CRYING.
EVERYONE NEEDS A STRESS
BALL.
MANY PEOPLE OWN STRESS PAL
BALLS.
THIS IS INTERPRESENTATION OF
>> Tucker: LET'S SAY WE HAD
A WAR.
I DON'T KNOW, PICK A
COUNTRY.
CHINA CHALLENGED US WHERE WE
HAD TO MOBILIZE A LARGE
NUMBER OF AMERICANS TO
DEFEND THE HOMELAND.
>> OKAY.
>> Tucker: BUT EVERYONE IS
CRYING.
WOULD ANYBODY BE LEFT TO
FIGHT THE WAR.
CAN YOU DEFEND A COUNTRY IF
YOU ARE ENCOURAGING KIDS TO
CRY ABOUT FINAL EXAMS.
>> IF EVERYONE TAKES A
MOMENT ASIDE TO CENTER
THEMSELVES, GROUND
THEMSELVES, HAVE A CRY,
MAYBE FOR TWO, THREE MINUTES
AND THEN GO FIGHT THAT ARE
WITH A, I'M SURE THE WAR
WOULD BE WON WITH PEOPLE
SUCH A GREAT STATE OF MIND.
>> Tucker: COULD YOU TAKE A
BREAK CONCEIVABLY BETWEEN
BATTLES TO CRY?
>> I THINK THE BREAK WOULD
HAVE TO BE DONE BEFORE THE
BATTLE BUT THEY WOULD BE IN
THE RIGHT MIND SET BEFORE
THAT BATTLE THAT THEY WOULD
WIN THAT BATTLE.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS
WHOLE CLOSET IS ABOUT.
THE CRY CLOSET IS ABOUT
GETTING THAT RIGHT STATE OF
MIND.
YEAH.
>> Tucker: WOULD YOU WANT TO
USE A CLOSET OTHERS HAVE
CRIED IN?
>> I DON'T THINK I WOULD
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT
SOUNDS VERY COZY AND GOOGLE
HAS DONE THIS OUT IN SILICON
VALLEY.
SO MANY COMPANIES HAVE
CREATED PING-PONG TABLES AND
VERY COMFORTABLE CORPORATE
SETTINGS WHERE PEOPLE CAN
LET OFF STEAM.
>> Tucker: IF A CRY CLOSET
IS CALLED FOR HOW ABOUT LIKE
A PETTING ZOO LIKE A BUNNY
STROKING STATION.
IS THAT TOO FAR?
COULD YOU ENVISION THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S THE
FUTURE.
IF PEOPLE ARE COMFORTABLE
AND WORK BETTER AFTER BEING
CENTERED AND CALMER, THEN
WHY NOT?
BRING THE BUNNIES IN, YES.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU A
MACROPOINT.
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT
THIS.
I DON'T WANT TO SHOCK YOU OR
ANYTHING.
I THOUGHT THE WHOLE IDEA WAS
TO GET PEOPLE TO COME OUT OF
THE CLOSET.
YOU ARE LOOKING IN THE
CAMERA AND SAY PEOPLE GO
BACK IN THE CLOSET.
DO YOU AS A PROGRESSIVE FEEL
GOOD ABOUT THAT.
>> GO IN FOR 10 MINUTES SO
CAN YOU COME OUT CONFIDENTLY
AND FEEL GOOD.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO GO INTO
THAT CRY CLOSET RIGHT BEFORE
THE SHOW AND HAVE A GREAT
SHOW AFTERWARDS.
>> Tucker: I KNOW THIS IS
LIKE TELEVISION AND YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE TOO HONEST.
LET'S TRY TO PUSH THE LEVER.
>> I'M ALWAYS HONEST WITH
YOU.
>> Tucker: IF YOU KNEW A MAN
I COULD DATE THAT MAN.
I'M SORRY I HAVE GOT TO TAKE
A QUICK BREAK AND GO CRY IN
A CLOSET WHILE SQUEEZING A
STUFFED ANIMAL, THAT WOULD
WRECK THE DEAL FOR IT,
HONESTLY.
>> PROBABLY SAY I'M GOING TO
GO CENTER MYSELF SO I CAN BE
A STRONGER, BETTER PERSON
FOR YOU, YEAH, I WOULD LOVE
THAT PERSON.
I THINK THAT'S GREAT.
I THINK THAT'S HEALTHY.
WHO DOESN'T WANT TO BE WITH
A HEALTHY PERSON.
>> Tucker: PART OF YOU WOULD
LOOK ON CON TEMP JUSTLY YOU
WEAK LITTLE FREAK STOP
CRYING, RIGHT?
>> WHAT A STRONG PERSON WHO
UNDERSTANDS THEMSELVES OR
HERSELF OR WHATEVER PRONOUN
THAT PERSON WISHES TO BE
CALLED.
>> Tucker: I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU FOR A SECOND.
YOU WOULD WANT TO THINK THAT
AS A GOOD PROGRESSIVE YOU
WOULD THINK THIS IS
WHOLESOME.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH MY
IDEOLOGY.
ON A GUT LEVEL YOU WOULD SAY
STOP WHIMPERING.
>> EVERY PLACE HAS A CRY
CLOSET AND EVERY PLACE HAS A
SAFE PLACE.
CRY CLOSET CAN BE THE
BATHROOM.
EVERYONE NEEDS A GOOD CRY
CLOSET.
OLD FASHIONED WAY OF LETTING
OUT STRESS AND RELIEVING
TENSION.
>> Tucker: I'M GOING TO
LEAVE IT.